[Music]
on this Tuesday night stepping down
Anthony wrote a bows to pressure and
resigns as House of Commons speaker I
reiterate my profound regret for my
error The Firestorm over celebrating a
man who fought for the Nazis
Hardeep Singh nijer's murder accounts of
what security video shows the night he
was gunned down
record high use of Canada's food banks
it's heartbreaking the potential ways to
alleviate poverty as stores struggle to
stop shoplifting and life in Yellowknife
after the Wildfire times are going to be
a little lean now the worries about a
difficult winter ahead
[Music]
a freezing good evening and thanks for
joining us there's more Fallout from the
standing ovation members of Canada's
House of Commons gave to a Ukrainian man
who fought with a Nazi unit during the
second world war Anthony Rota the
Speaker of the House of Commons has
resigned he's the MP who invited 98 year
old yarislav hunka to be in the gallery
when Ukraine's president addressed
Parliament last week hunka was
recognized as a Ukrainian hero when it
later became clear he'd fought with the
Nazis the pressure on Rhoda was intense
I reiterate my profound regret for my
error in recognizing an individual in
the house during the joint address to
Parliament of president zielinski
the whole episode is not only
embarrassing for Canada Russia is using
it in its propaganda about its war on
Ukraine Mackenzie gray has our top story
tonight
early this morning the mood was clear I
can't see based on the conversations
that I've had that he will continue to
have the support of liberal members of
parliament I think the speaker should
listen
to members of the House
and step down with all four major
parties calling for speaker Anthony
wrote his departure the inevitable can
it's with a heavy heart
that I Rise to inform members of my
resignation as Speaker of the House of
Commons Rhoda becoming the first Speaker
since 1986 to quit after he not only
invited he's a Ukrainian hero a Canadian
hero
but honored and 98 year old man who
fought in a Nazi unit after Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski's speech to
Parliament on Friday that public
recognition has caused pain to
individuals and communities
including the Jewish community in Canada
and around the world in addition to
survivors of Nazi atrocities in Poland
among other nations the speaker's office
says yaroslav hunka's son asked if the
Nazi link veteran could attend
zielinski's appearance and wrote his
team obliged but that explanation not
good enough for the opposition this man
is not a hero he is a monster and he had
no business being here the parliament
has been tarnished and so many people
have been hurt by what happened last
Friday Jewish groups applauding wrote
his resignation but also won an apology
from the Prime Minister our reputation
as a nation is being besmirched around
the world this is the time for
leadership this is the time for a prime
minister to to step forward and explain
what happened very clearly the Polish
government hoping for more suggesting
they're considering asking for hunka to
be extradited to Warsaw I'm sure this
request will be considered and at The
Institute of national remembrance and
the possibility some steps will follow
after Rhoda's announcement he left the
chair and didn't preside over question
period but he doesn't officially end his
duties until Wednesday evening Donna at
which point the commons will need to
elect a new speaker
Mac a new speaker will be elected but I
guess we don't know how long that might
take yeah and it's getting to happen
fairly quickly Donna because the rules
for the House of Commons say they can't
do any other business like votes or hold
question period until that new speaker
is elected but as of now there isn't a
date for that so we heard from NDB house
Leader Peter Julian erter he told
reporters that he thinks a vote will
take place next week because MPS need to
be in the chamber in Ottawa and can't
participate virtually like they do for
QP and I'm sure MPC want the job Donna
would also like the weekend to quietly
Lobby for the prestigious dig that comes
with a beautiful home in Chelsea Quebec
but whenever the vote does happen it'll
be held by secret ballot and the dean of
the House of Commons block MP Louis
plummond Dom will preside over it Donna
okay Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
India's foreign minister addressed the
United Nations today and made an
indirect reference to Canada as the
Diplomatic dispute between Canada and
India deepens Delhi continues to call
the assertion its agents were involved
in the murder of a Canadian sick leader
absurd Toria isri reports
India is trying to position itself as a
rising Global power and that includes a
visit to the United Nations and an
interview with an American Think Tank
where the Indian foreign minister told
the crowd New Delhi does not carry out
extrajudicial killings this is not the
government of India's policy
two we told the Canadians saying that
look if you have something specific if
you have something relevant
you know let us know we are open to
looking at it he also dug in repeating
India's claim Canada is Sheltering
terrorists and criminals and is two
lakhs on six separatists
we have actually been badgering the
Canadians so we have given them lot of
information last week prime minister
Justin Trudeau revealed Canada has
credible intelligence India may be
linked to the killing of Canadian sick
leader harjit Singh Niger I can confirm
what the Prime Minister shared publicly
that there is clear intelligence that
Canada has India calls the allegation
absurd credible allegations while a
bizarre smear campaign against Trudeau
is underway in Indian media
with unfounded claims the Prime Minister
brought cocaine onto his plane during
his visit for the G20
it's against this backdrop a senior
Canadian military officer traveled to
the Indian capital for a gathering of
army Chiefs Major General Peter Scott
spoke with Indian news agency Ani I'm
fully aware of the Prime Minister
Trudeau is a statement the government
stance and the government's request for
India to participate in and cooperate in
the investigation but really that has no
impact on us here at the indo-pacific
conference New Delhi is hosting that
conference as Western leaders
countered China they're also not happy
about this coming out publicly the way
it has come because there's a great deal
at stake
questions about what the Diplomatic
dispute
Canada's
indo-tire section dedicated to India the
country is a pillar in the year old
strategy and right now that pillar is
shaky
teria is Reit Global News Ottawa
the investigation into the murder of a
sick leader at the heart of all of this
is ongoing no one has been arrested
there is security camera video that
shows a little bit of what unfolded that
night in June in Surrey BC The
Washington Post and the New York Times
have spoken to people who say they've
seen the video and are reporting that
what happened was more complex than what
police have described our Kamal caramale
is in Surrey where he's been speaking to
people Kamel what have you learned Donna
to be clear Global News has not seen the
video but spoke to three independent
people who have including the
spokesperson for the guru nanak Gurdwara
here in Surrey BC and it paints a
harrowing picture leading up to the
fatal shooting now the they say the
video shows Hardeep Singh niger's truck
pulling out of its parking spot the
video then allegedly shows niger's truck
speed up while a Vite a white van starts
driving beside the truck through the
parking lot the truck then reaches the
exit but the white van then pulls in
front to block Ninja's truck from
leaving the parking lot that car was
used as a blocker car to block Mr
Hardeep Singh Nigerian while the
Assassins came and shot at him from the
driver's seat that car made his way out
and quickly after that the Assassins
they moved out as well so from watching
that video we could tell that this
wasn't something that was done abruptly
or it was in the random act that this
was well planned orchestrated now the
Gurdwara spokespeople also said that the
video shows the two gunmen going into a
silver car afterwards with three other
individuals now the good war is choosing
not to make the video public because of
the police investigation and they're now
conducting an internal investigation of
their own to determine who leaked it to
the Washington Post
and Kamal there have been some reports
police were slow to respond to the scene
back in June what do you know about that
yeah there's plenty of criticism on the
arrival time of police so Witnesses say
that it took up to 15 minutes or around
15 minutes for the police to arrive
after the shooting itself and that there
was a disagreement between Surrey police
officers and RCMP on who should take the
lead on scene Surrey police have said
that is not true but did not speak
specifically on how long it took
officers to arrive there's also growing
criticism on why investigators ask the
Public's help to search for the silver
getaway vehicle but did not publicly say
anything about the white van allegedly
involved or that there were as many as
six people and what they're calling a
coordinated attack and Donna so far
there have been no suspects identified
by police back over to you all right
Kamal karamali and Suri BC tanks 15
potential unmarked Graves have been
found near a former residential school
in the Yukon researchers use ground
penetrating radar to scan more than 37
thousand square meters of land at the
former troot residential school in car
cross they say more invasive work is
needed to confirm if the sites are
Graves but their locations are
consistent with survivors accounts and
thousands of archival documents
opening arguments in the trial of Peter
Nygaard have begun in Toronto the crown
laying out its case that the former
fashion Mogul used his power and status
to lure and sexually assault young women
the 82 year old has pleaded not guilty
to five counts of sexual assault in one
count of forcible confinement the crown
alleges all five complainants in the
case were brought to nygaard's office
building in Toronto where he forced
himself on them the crown also told the
jury the bedroom door had automatic
locks and no handles the trial is
expected to go on for seven weeks Nygard
faces separate charges in Manitoba and
Quebec and is set to be extradited to
the U.S to face charges there once these
Canadian criminal cases are finished
there is a troubling new picture of how
many Canadians are turning to food banks
to feed themselves and their families
food banks Canada says roughly 2.8
million Canadians are unable to afford
basic necessities and live in poverty in
its Country-Wide report card seven
provincial governments received a d Plus
or worse for their weak approach to
Poverty reduction Quebec got the highest
grade A B minus it wrote the country's
first poverty reduction strategy in
2002. Nova Scotia got the worst grade
and F our business reporter nivrita
gangali takes a deep dive into the
report with the cost of food
housing and nearly all Essentials On The
Rise food banks have become vital for an
increasing number of families struggling
to make ends meet it's heartbreaking
we're seeing the highest level of food
bank use in Canadian history new
research by food banks Canada shows
nearly 43 percent of Canadians feel
financially worse off compared to last
year and 18 are experiencing food
insecurity volunteers on the front lines
say the data is not surprising last year
our Network received 403 000 visits to
over 100 agencies across Ottawa this
year we're expecting to have those
visits uh reach almost 500 000. in a
series of poverty report cards food
banks Canada has graded Canada's
territories and provinces on efforts to
reduce poverty and the results don't
look good Quebec scored highest with a B
minus a five percent poverty rate low
food insecurity and stronger social
assistance have all helped what's
positive is that when you do make a
concerted effort you will see progress
we saw that with the grade that Quebec
is being given but Nova Scotia fed the
worst on metrics like food insecurity
social assistance standard of living and
legislative efforts to reduce poverty
what's really driving the upgrade in
Nova Scotia is in action what we're
seeing is a stagnation around any sort
of progress to alleviate poverty on from
a policy perspective in this report food
banks Canada has outlined detailed
policy recommendations for governments
at the federal and provincial levels a
national rent supplement program is one
suggestion another is extending GSE tax
credits until the inflation rate reaches
that two percent Target I mean what
we've done with the poverty report cards
this year is provide very actionable
policy recommendations built for the
governments in place they're realistic
and they're they're really doable for
government
Global News Toronto
the politics of Labor disputes coming up
why American President Joe Biden turned
up on a picket line today
[Music]
this is a first a sitting American
president joining striking Auto Workers
on the picket line in Michigan it is an
extraordinary show of support for
organized labor by a president who needs
to win over voters Michigan is a key
swing state it has a powerful block of
Voters former president Donald Trump is
expected to be there on Wednesday and as
Brittany Rosen reports they're
delivering dueling messages to the same
audience
would you deserve what you've earned and
you've earned a hell of a lot more than
you're getting paid now in a historic
moment U.S President Biden met with Auto
Workers fist bumping their efforts in
fighting for higher wages Biden's visit
is strategic coming during a tense race
for re-election
yeah
Trump is slated to join the picket line
Wednesday both candidates vying to
capture critical swing States like
Michigan where unions are influential
Biden has claimed that he is the most
pro-union
um president in in history Biden won
Michigan during the 2020 election but
Trump took the state in 2016.
the UAW has been on strike for 12 days
18 000 workers across dozens of states
have walked off the job and those work
stoppages could result in significant
supply chain disruptions service units
dealership repair maintenance service
operations they may just start telling
people that you know we don't have the
parts we can't do the Service Experts
say the economic Fallout of the strike
could make or break candidates run for
presidency this could be very dangerous
for Biden because that seems to be the
one issue where voters don't feel like
they have a lot of confidence in him and
Trump's strategy of course will be to
capitalize on that also of no to Donna
while Biden continues to tout his status
as the most pro-labor president the UAW
has yet to endorse his bid for
re-election I'll send things back to you
all right Brittany Rosen in Washington
thanks
a fire during a wedding in Northern Iraq
has killed at least 100 people and
injured many more according to the Iraqi
national news agency it appears to have
started when fireworks were set off
inside the events Hall and highly
flammable panels on the walls were
quickly engulfed in flames the bride and
groom are believed to be among the
victims according to local media
[Music]
Rising rates of violent shoplifting in
Canada ahead we explore the potential
Solutions
as many Canadians struggle to keep up
with the rising cost of living the
impacts are being felt across the retail
sector there's been a big increase in
violent shoplifting not just in Canada
but in many countries as Mike your lay
reports finding a solution isn't simple
foreign
on the streets of Toronto the lengths
retailers will take to curb shoplifting
is on Full display
it's a battle retailers are increasingly
worried they're losing violent incidents
are up and while police make the
occasional large bust store owners like
Chris scholes and Calgary have yet to
see a deterrent and that includes jail
that works they're very entitled they
feel that it's their right and that
our feelings don't matter to them they
will do whatever it takes to get what
they want and they are very forceful
with it I want to see an office for
violence reduction
reporting very close to the mayor in
every major city in Canada criminologist
Irvin Waller has been studying the trend
for decades there's an overnight
solution he doesn't have it but he says
programs focusing on social Outreach
Youth Development mentoring and positive
parenting have been proven to reduce
violent crime by 50 percent over five
years in other cities like Glasgow
Scotland and London England and I think
the issue is not you know tough on crime
or tough on causes it's getting smart on
crime and smart on crime means you
you're using evidence and the evidence
shows that in various cities pilot
projects to curb crime work but they
don't have a lasting effect there's lots
of
resources being poured into the response
but there doesn't seem to be any kind of
a coordinated
strategy in terms of how are we going to
get the outcomes and I feel like too
much of what we're doing is driven by
ideology rather than evidence and good
data and outcomes on Parliament Hill a
rise in shoplifting doesn't appear to be
on the liberal radar Minister of Justice
ARA ferrani says it hasn't come up in
discussions about crime a fact that
leaves the conservatives perplexed in
fact we're hearing from a lot of
businesses that they're calling police
exacerb you know just exhausted from all
of the the losses and insurance claims
and the abuse it's not quite an epidemic
but retailers and police are hoping
Ottawa hears them before it turns into
one microwave Global News Toronto
recovering Revenue next year's in yellow
and I small businesses will go under
after a season disrupted by fires
wildfires not only change the landscape
and burn down homes they can change the
economy especially if small towns and
cities in Yellowknife there are huge
financial losses and some business
owners fear they won't be able to
survive the winter Heather urich's West
spoke to locals about the difficult road
ahead
it was supposed to be a day of
Celebration but last Saturday almost two
weeks after residents of Yellowknife
returned to their Northern Community the
skies overhead were dark and red you're
kind of constantly reminded that you're
not really in a safe place
um and something bad could happen at any
moment there was no immediate danger but
the air quality forced the city to
cancel its welcome home party plans one
more challenge for a region that has
already been through a lot that we're
not going to give up on your life yet
but I think without some supports coming
in financially we're we're going to see
another Exodus from from the territory
that's because for most northern
residents evacuations that spanned
several weeks came with significant
out-of-pocket costs more than the
territories one-time support payment
covered I think times are going to be a
little lean now for the next couple
months and especially moving into the
Christmas season with people having
spent so much money on evacuation but
it's a difficult reality facing small
businesses now as they try to cover
Revenue that's been lost I teach yoga
retreats and I had one booked for
September 1st to 5th at Frontier fishing
lodge where I teach an annual Wellness
Retreat and that was canceled and it's
one of my biggest Retreats of the year
the territory is offering grants to
small businesses up to five thousand
dollars to offset costs but for some
that support doesn't go far enough
listening to stories of some of the
other small businesses were
like kind of heartbreaking you realize
that you know their lives like
livelihoods are on the line right now
and it's possible that the north will
see a lot of small businesses shut down
it's why yellowknife's Chamber of
Commerce believes Federal funding will
also be required the approach in Winter
may bring the summer long fire fight to
an end but in these weary Northern
Communities there is still an urgent
need for help Heather York's West Global
News
and that is global national for this
Tuesday I'm Donna freeze and tonight's
your Canada is Pine Beach in doorbell
Quebec thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]